Do you ever anticipate yourself
traveling for journalism again? Sure. Oh,
town travel. Yeah. But just
nothing like this. Yeah. No,
I don't need to do dangerous
travel anytime soon. No, no.
Yeah. Some people just want to jump right
back into the fire. Yeah, that's not,
but that was not the point in the first
place. Right. What was the point like,
what did you hope to get out of
this trip to Somalia? Well, so one,
one thing that I noticed while
I was watching the trial and,
um,
in,
in Hamburg was this clash
between a modern liberal state,
which is what Germany is. Um, and
so it was American by the way. Um,
and in archaic crime and Germany in fact
is newer than the United States in the
sense that its constitution was written
in 1949 when nobody was thinking about
piracy.
So the laws against piracy or extremely
lenient in German law in a way that
they're not in Spanish or American law.
Um,
we have laws that date back
to when it was a capital crime
and basically the Germans did not
to deal with these guys. And, uh,
I thought it was fascinating in the
first place that this ancient crime had
revived after a couple of centuries
of relative quiet, you know, and,
um,
so I,
that tension on its own was interesting
and that was worth the book because
nobody was quite approaching
it that way, you know? Uh,
so that tension is still interesting
and that tension is still alive.
So there are certainly threats to modern
liberal states going on around the
world. So what were the
trials in Berlin? Uh,
there was a trial in Hamburg and I was
going back and forth from Berlin. Uh,
it was 10 guys from Somalia who I tried
to hijack a cargo ship that belonged to
a,
um,
a German ship ship company
that was based in Hamburg.
Uh, I think they were
overpowered by the Dutch navy,
but the Dutch handed him over to the
Germans. In fact, the Dutch said, okay,
we'll do this as long as we don't have
to try them because everyone knew from
the outset that there was going to
be a problem, uh, trying Somalis,
um, in what way? Um,
in Europe in general,
but especially in Germany,
I think there's a actually a law against
shipping them back to Somalia because
it's considered not a safe
place, um, for them, for them,
even for them. And I think that's
nuts. Once they were convicted,
I think they should have been deported
after they serve their tongue.
It's so bizarre. But, but if they
were shipped back to Somalia,
how would they be treated? Like what
does the government like in Somalia? Man,
good questions. Sanely corrupt. I asked
some of my parents about that. Um,
it is corrupt. It's a, it's either
corrupt or nonexistent. So the,
the government of Somalia is,
are focused around Mogadishu and it
just doesn't have that much power in the
provinces.
And I was in one of the,
one of the provinces and because of the
provinces don't get a whole lot of money
from Mogadishu so that they run their own
businesses, wins in some cases, piracy.
Um,
I asked one of my guards what would happen
if a pirate went and got thrown into
jail and some of the country and then
came back and tried to, you know,
set up friendships again with his old
pirate buddies or whatever, you know,
would he be killed? Who would he be
in, in dangerous? No, no, no problem.
It was probably what you worry
about again. No problem. Yeah. Yeah.
I mean,
is there any sort of punishment for them
when they get back to Somalia news or
any penal system or a
potentially there is, yeah.
So that's not considered a crime.
There are, yes, it is. So there,
there are laws on the books,
especially in the regions, um,
and even prisons for pirates.
Um,
the problem is that clan relationships
are a lot more important than newly
written laws. Um, and so
even prior to go to jail,
this was true about one boss. In my case,
I'm might cut out again. So this guy,
this guy who was a pirate Boston,
my case wound up in jail while I was
still captive for one month in Mogadishu
and wound up walking. Wow. Yeah.
And he was captive for piracy I think
for having weapons that the government
didn't expect to see in one of his houses.
So a,
there's something off to the side,
but it's really sketchy system
of bartering and payoffs
and who you know and who
you're related to. And the, there
are other prisons for, you know,
low ranking pirates in Puntland
and also in Galkayo where I was,
um, it's a crap shoot how much time
those guys are going to spend in jail.
And what happened with
the people in Germany?
They got a total of seven years I think,
or an average in Germany,
in Germany.
And then what happened when they
were released? Nothing. Wow. Yeah.
Um, that's a whole separate story,
which I haven't even started.
It started to address,
but as it turned out,
a few of them went back to Somalia anyway.
It probably went right back into the
business a well or something else. Uh,
you know, elicit or
profitable or whatever. Yeah.
And there's a wide variety
of people that they target.
They target people and individual crafts,
the target large boats,
commercial vessels. Yup.
They did all of that. I mean,
in fact I met hostage is from all of
those, you know, from the whole range.
So the company hostage, did you meet
over the two years and eight months? Um,
a total of 30. So the, the
crew on the fishing ship,
the tune of vessel was 28 and then I
met to say shall Wah Wah fishermen.
The two guys from the Seychelles,
we're small time.
So they were just on a small craft.
Would it say shells in the Seychelles is
a chain of islands off Africa. It's a,
it's a country that belongs to
Africa. Um, but it has a French name.
Um, the, the guys on the tune of vessel,
um, we're from a, you know, relatively
big ship. The guys from the Seychelles,
we're from a small private craft.
And I was an example of
someone captured on land
and these people that were from
the small private co craft it.
Who were they trying to get money from?
Just anyone who knows them.
Is that how they do this? Yeah,
whoever. Anybody. They can, I mean,
of course they asked the government,
but the government doesn't always pay,
you know,
the given government.
Yeah. It's just, it,
it's just the whole system seems
so insane that they've got, I mean,
the key people for years and years,
but they have just a whole collection of
them or they're trying to extract money
from people that
no, them. Yeah. Uh, as it turns
out, they're not very good at it.
So pirates are in the kidnapping business,
but they don't always know
what they're doing. Um, the,
the bosses I think got used to,
um,
demanding a lot of money from shipping
companies and finding out that if you
hold a ship stubbornly for a long time,
I,
you got a lot of money from the
insurance company or whatever. Um,
I that, that calculation doesn't work
with human beings. So in other words,
everyone else on earth who,
who negotiates for a human being expects
of the person's price to go down as the
time, you know, wears on. And, um, it took
a while for pirates to understand that,
wow. What is it? I mean, when you're
d you're dealing with all this,
like what, what is it like on your
psyche when you're getting two years in,
two and a half years in and you,
you,
you have some sort of light
at the end of the tunnel.
What, what is it, what
does it feel like? Well,
I didn't know there was light at
the end of the tunnel. So, um,
two years in that's where, um, you know,
it was either forgive the guards
or, or, or self destruct. Um,
it was also,
by then I had also
deliberately given let go of having any
kind of hope so that that was a second
survival strategy. I, I had to,
I'm not hope that I was going to get out,
uh,
because hoping was had a downside,
that cycle of hope and despair,
it was extremely damaging
my mental wellbeing. So the,
after going through that
cycle a few times, I'm like,
I have to find a different way.
Hmm.
One of the things that I've gotten out
of travel is I think it it your view of
the world changes when you see the way
people are living in different places.
You, you, your spectrum expands.
You start recognizing like, oh,
I might be used to southern California
but this is not how they do things in
Ohio.
This is not how they do things in Italy.
This is not when you go as far
as being a captive in Somalia,
your,
your spectrum is massive.
I mean your view of the world
being entrenched in that
life and being with those
people,
whether chewing his narcotic and carrying
around coalition of coughs and yelling
at each other in a foreign language and
watching fist fights and realizing like
they don't have anything either.
What w how much has that changed you as
a human being and you or your view of
human life on earth?
Well, I think enormously. I mean, I,
you're right, it expanded my range and my,
my understanding of, of
what other people think, um,
they obviously come from a completely
different perspective and smelly and not
only are they, um, Muslim and African,
but they're also very isolated.
So Somalia as a,
as a rule has always been difficult
to penetrate for outsiders.
That was true when Richard Burton was
there in the 19th century too. Um, it's,
it's a closed culture and,
um,
they have their own way of thinking.
And also the office of the language
is not related to most other languages
you've heard,
unless you,
you're familiar with languages in Ethiopia
to learn any of it. Yeah, a little bit.
But, um, I, I resisted
learning it from the guards.
I think when I was there,
I thought about it like,
I'm in Berlin, you realize that
a lot of east Germans when,
um,
during the communist era,
we're taught Russian in school
and a lot of them hated it.
And I was not in a mood to learn
Somalia Somali once I was a captain.
So, um, it was similar to that. I, uh,
I learned a few words, but I
never had a good teacher. Um,
and of course when I was a journalist,
I was relying on translators.
I would imagine that as a writer,
that spectrum,
the expansion of the spectrum,
although there's no way you would ever
barter it off or bargain to have those
experiences to broaden your spectrum.
It has to have changed the way you put
pen to paper and view the world and your,
your ability to describe things.
Yeah.
I think you,
you realize that each
individual has certain, certain
boundaries, you know, and,
and certain certain self definitions.
Um,
and those self definitions can be
the,
the distance between one individual
and another can be enormous,
but in some sense also they're
superficial distinctions. So yeah,
they're inescapable.
Reality is so alien in comparison
to someone who lives in Bel Air.
Oh, absolutely. Just this, this,
just that contrast between this world
that you are so deeply entrenched in for
two and two years and eight months like
that has got to change the way you look
at human life.
Yeah.
Uh,
because the Gulf and
wealth is so enormous.
I mean they can't imagine that the amount
of money it takes to live in Bel air
and the other way around.
I mean,
I think it's very difficult for someone
in California to imagine how little you
can get by on,
um,
and how close to the earth most
people on the planet live. Yeah.
There's a statistic
that I read once that I,
I repeat all the time cause it still
baffles me that if you make more than
$34,000 a year, you're in the 1% of
the world of the world. Yeah. Possibly.
Yeah.
And that is probably magnified
many fold in Ethiopia.
Yeah. In Ethiopia and Somalia.
I mean it's, it's very, um,
you know, in some ways, although
they want money all the time,
especially if they're criminals,
um,
the money that we're used to sort of
greasing our path through life around here
is just not available. It's just
not, not part of the reality.
What do they do with money when
they get it? Well, it depends if,
if they're pirates,
they splash out on fancy car or,
or caught, you see fancy cars from sure.
Oh yeah, no, I was placed in fancy cars.
I mean, yeah, no. So the pirates
had great cell phones, um,
expensive SUV. Yes. Um, weapons
that they had bought, you know,
from abroad and maybe a weapons bizarre
in Mogadishu or something like that. Uh,
but that's not cheap either. Uh,
they, they bragged about how the, uh,
the bullets costs like a dollar each,
you know, and the one of them might,
might've been wearing a band of 500
bullets. Um, and the cut is expensive.
So lots of things costs an enormous
amount of money in Somalia. But if you're,
you know, if you're a very
ordinary Somali, Somali, you,
you're getting by on
less than a dollar a day.
So there's the ordinary Somalis who are
not criminals or not pirates at least.
And then you can ask the majority,
the majority.
And then you have these
pirates that are essentially
running through the
streets and Mercedes Benz,
they're like gangsters. They're
like gangsters. And that's,
that's actually how one Somali, who
had some connection to Germany, um,
describing them to me, you know, he,
he was wandering around and
got Kyle because it was his
hometown and in some way
or ancestral ancestral town. And he had
met some, this was before I got captured.
It was like they were, you know, they
had wrapped thumping from the SUV.
Did they really? American rap.
Who knows, who knows this?
There's lots of actually good
African ramp. Really? Oh yeah.